hands gum brass money's pierpass so
today we're going to do something
completely new something I shouldn't do
because I don't know anything about
music
but I got a looper you can't see it uh
Brad lent it to me and it's a lot of fun
I am I'm still new at it so I'm not I'm
not trying to show off I'm just trying
to have some fun so don't get the wrong
idea from this video I asked you bros on
Facebook what I should make a song about
so I got a couple suggestions and I'm
gonna make a quick song for each not
each one but a couple of them and it'll
be a I'll be cool I'll be fun alright
let studious make a song about ducks so
we're going to do that
quack-quack-quack I love God
they make me wonder fun I took a job in
the ass what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] oh I
love me some jerk they make me want a
son I [ __ ] a good one still telling
what about it though it's kind of weird
don't tell anyone I [ __ ] I don't dope
is my life don't is what I do I [ __ ] a
dog and I don't wanna [ __ ] you I [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] that's right a full dose
Ayisha shelter wants me to make a song
about my but have you ever sucked on my
ass answer that truly um do you want to
suck on my ass where your life is about
to change [ __ ] son pass ass gas chance
ss SS ss SS ss SS ss SS ss SS ss SS ss
SS haters Bodie is all that bacon one
agrees makes me wanna swags to us what
this boy is danced my booty is smooth
the smoothing yes
Reuben seed isn't the third Edgar
yes fork Fork [ __ ] yes that was the best
[ __ ] song I almost teared up that was
[ __ ] beautiful Moo code Gump that
make a song about haters
haters can suck it suck a dick so suck a
dick haters all right that was a lot of
fun I hope you bros enjoyed that if you
want me to make a song about anything
leave a comment down below and that's it
for me
thank you boys for watching I'll see in
the next one stay awesome risk
Skippy's obtaining [ __ ]
yes give me some cherries almonds yeah
we some teddy [ __ ] yuck your mr. tan it
ought to be what it better